avant définition de fume c'est un
tableau pour que ces acteurs comprennent
exactement ce qu'il veut kurzawa leur
fait un dessin kurzawa le m le doyen des
réalisateurs est un vrai pédagogue ce
que doit être une vraie pédagogie celle
sujet de l'histoire d'un écrivain ancien
professeur les élèves y sont tellement
reconnaissants de les avoir aidés à
devenir des hommes et pas seulement des
cadres supérieurs qui lui organise
régulièrement des fêtes toujours
surprenante qui doit même assister le
jour de son anniversaire à la mise en
scène de son propre enterrement à chaque
fête comme des enfants qui jouent à
cache-cache les élèves lui pose la
question
lou ye tu sous-entendus et du prêt à
passer dans l'autre monde et il répond
mme haddad ayo le titre du film
pas encore
le plus important dans un enseignement
c'est de savoir apprendre à vivre pour
devenir un véritable être humain leur
ozawa a lui aussi ses disciples ses
anciens assistants sont tous devenus
réalisateurs alors été lui-même un m
adulé comme celui de son film les
principaux membres de mon équipe
m'appelle monsieur kurzawa mais tous les
autres m'appelle m c'est une habitude
japonaise les jeunes je leur demande de
ne pas parler comme le maître du film de
kurosawa à intel en particulier pour
enseigner à travers sa propre vie des
choses aussi simples est fondamental que
la compassion
l'humidité où la dignité dans l'épreuve
et de dénuement sa récompense
c'est que jamais ces élèves ne
l'abandonnerons